KORY JEFFREY:
Welcome, everybody.
We are at Founder
World in San Francisco.
I am joined by Michael, the CEO
and co-founder of HomeSwipe.
Michael, thank you for joining.
MICHAEL LISOVETSKY:
Thank you for having me.
KORY JEFFREY: Awesome.
So let's start with
what is HomeSwipe?
MICHAEL LISOVETSKY: HomeSwipe is
an apartment renting platform,
and it really helps people
find their apartment
in a much easier way.
Right now we're just
in New York City,
but we set out with
the goal of taking
this overwhelming process
and just breaking it down
into a really simple
step-by-step process.
KORY JEFFREY: OK.
And so you're
competing with things
like Craigslist, or
whatever massive listing,
MLS, things like that.
What's the difference?
What's the difference in the
experience between your app
and what they're doing?
MICHAEL LISOVETSKY: It's really
reimagining the fundamentals
that go into it,
the inputs, meaning
our app is very much focused
on taking that large data set
of apartment rentals
and breaking it
down into bite-sized,
just actionable pieces.
So it looks kind of like Tinder.
You would swipe left to skip
and then swipe right to favorite
or to chat on it, and
it's really simple,
but that kind of card setup
UI is actually very powerful.
KORY JEFFREY: Right.
MICHAEL LISOVETSKY: You
could take a large data set
and mull it down into
simple yes/no decisions.
KORY JEFFREY: Yeah.
That's pretty cool.
So obviously, you're dealing
with search, probably
a lot of technical challenges
that come along with that.
Any in particular that
stuck out as you kind of go
through that process?
MICHAEL LISOVETSKY: There's a
lot of technical challenges.
I mean, we've made our
fair share of mistakes.
I'm actually the CEO.
I'm technical, but not
even near as much as my--
KORY JEFFREY: Not
working on the code?
MICHAEL LISOVETSKY: Yeah,
exactly, as much as my CTO.
What I've learned from
my CTO, who is young,
is that joins are
very important.
So we thought we'd
get away with MongoDB
and having that
kind of database,
but we ended up using Postgres.
And we've rewritten the
backend a few times,
and we've made our
fair share of mistakes.
But real estate data
is very verbose,
and a lot of it's
just XML feeds of just
verbose, verbose, verbose,
verbose data, this legacy data
that I had no idea that
we'd be putting up with.
KORY JEFFREY: Sure.
MICHAEL LISOVETSKY: So
it's been interesting.
KORY JEFFREY: Interesting.
That's pretty cool.
So you were speaking
today at Founder World.
What was it that you
were speaking about?
What's the message you
were trying to get across?
MICHAEL LISOVETSKY:
So I was just
on a panel about how
important talent is
and really just going up against
rejection and breaking through.
KORY JEFFREY: Right.
MICHAEL LISOVETSKY: Because it
was just a bunch of founders.
We were on a panel, and we
were discussing how, really,
the challenges of
becoming a founder,
and then going
through with that.
My goal was really to deliver
a message of perseverance
and of pushing through.
Because even if you hear no
100 times, you just need one
yes to really make that
breakthrough progress.
So it's really that
perseverance that matters.
KORY JEFFREY: Very cool.
So you came from New York,
I assume, because you're
based out of there.
MICHAEL LISOVETSKY: Yep.
So I'm based in New York.
KORY JEFFREY: Still
based in New York.
So what made you come
to Founder World?
Why Founder World?
MICHAEL LISOVETSKY: It was
just an incredible opportunity.
And the little
success that I've had
thus far, the little
opportunities for success
I've had, have come from just
really interesting environments
like Founder World.
KORY JEFFREY: Right.
MICHAEL LISOVETSKY:
Environments where
there's a huge density of people
that are in the same space
thinking the same way, and it
just-- it yields opportunity.
Events like Founder World
always yield opportunity.
KORY JEFFREY: Right.
Yeah, for sure.
It's been great.
It's been a great atmosphere.
So as you walk around today,
as you look at the booths,
there's all sorts of different
types of technologies,
from robots going around outside
to VR to-- everything's here.
Is there anything,
other than what
you're working on that excites
you for the future of tech?
MICHAEL LISOVETSKY:
There's a lot.
It's just everything is so cool.
A lot of people
nowadays, they're
kind of letting go of
this idea of limits,
and they've started
reimagining what technology
is to the day to day.
Sort of like Knightscope,
the little robots that
are running around outside that
people are taking selfies with.
It's incredible to think
that a robot can actually
replace-- to be a much better
replacement to the security
guard.
It's kind of wonky, but
it's this crazy enough idea
that's still attainable.
So it says to me
that a lot of people
have crazy ideas nowadays, but
they still feel attainable.
They're like, oh, that
could actually happen.
And self-driving cars, it's-- 30
years ago it was just a dream.
Our Back to the
Future Day was funny,
because a lot of the
things that we've
had that were present
in "Back to the Future,"
we actually have
today or some form of.
KORY JEFFREY: That's right.
MICHAEL LISOVETSKY:
It's incredible.
KORY JEFFREY: Yeah.
It's pretty cool.
Awesome.
So speaking of technology,
what is your favorite Google
technology?
MICHAEL LISOVETSKY: So, I mean,
there's a lot of amazing things
that Google does.
Search is a big
one, because it's
like the backend of my mind.
KORY JEFFREY: Right.
MICHAEL LISOVETSKY: And
then Maps is awesome too,
but it's not as accessible
for startups yet.
KORY JEFFREY: Right.
MICHAEL LISOVETSKY:
So that'd be very cool
if Maps was more accessible.
KORY JEFFREY: That's
something we could take back
to the Maps team?
MICHAEL LISOVETSKY: Absolutely.
KORY JEFFREY: Awesome.
Michael, it was great
for you to join me,
so thank you very much.
MICHAEL LISOVETSKY: Cool.
Thanks for having me.
KORY JEFFREY: And thank
you for joining me.
We're at Founder World in
San Francisco, and I'm Kory.
[MUSIC PLAYING]